who wants their applications to be
maintainable
quick show of hands
i'd really like to talk to people who
did not raise their hands right now
i think that maintainability is the most
important thing
developers should be aiming for and care
about
it opens up doors to everything else we
want to achieve
if your application is maintainable you
can make changes to it really quickly
you can keep your business owners or
your product managers
happy by being able to quickly add new
features
you can also remove new features remove
features or change how something works
without too much sweat on your end
and at the same time you can keep
yourself and your fellow developers
happy
by working in a code base which just
doesn't feel like a dumpster fire
a code base where technical debt is
under control
a code base which has predictable when
well understood behavior and
dependencies
a code base where you can rely on the
same business logic
being done the same way everywhere as
opposed to four in four different ways
in four different places
a code base which is super easy to test
automatically
so you can have high confidence when
you're shipping it
a world where you as a maintainer feel
happy not frustrated to work on it
and an application that you can offer to
your customers with pride and confidence
and it goes even further lack of
maintainability will really hinder your
ability to grow and scale
you simply won't be able to achieve
maximum scalability and performance
with an application that you're scared
to touch or which simply cannot be
modified without a significant rewrite
so maintainability really is the holy
grail of good software design
so this brings us to the focus of my
talk which is
good software architecture which ensures
maintainability
this building is a concert hall in
reykjavik in iceland
called harpa where we had our gophercon
eu last year
and the clue to the name of the one
particular pattern that i want to talk
about today is in this building
it's hexagonal architecture
it's actually the unofficial name um
it's the more common name for the ports
and adapters architecture which was
described by aleister coburn on his blog
in 2005.
he was not the only person to come up
with the idea
as early as 1992 ivor jacobson published
a pattern called the bce
boundary controller entity or or it was
later renamed to ebi entity boundary
interactor
in his book on of object-oriented
software engineering
he is the godfather of object-oriented
programming
then aleister coburn published his blog
post on the ports and adapters idea in
2005
giving it the alternative name of
hexagonal architecture which is what it
then became
more commonly known as
around 2008 jeffrey palermo
independently came up with a very
similar pattern which he called the
onion architecture
and then robert martin uncle bob he
referenced all of those ideas and a few
other ones in his book on clean
architecture but actually he referenced
some of those ideas much earlier on on
his blog in 2011 and 12 when he was
talking about the screaming architecture
and the clean architecture
so this very same same idea keep kept
being reinvented under different names
and talked independently over so many
years
so maybe that's a clue that it's a good
one so i thought i'll talk about the hex
architecture simply because an image of
harpa is a little bit more captivating
than an image of a bunch of onions
and also onions make you cry
hex architecture doesn't
so this is a diagram illustrating the
ports and adapters architecture
it shows that an application is composed
of three layers
the core layer which is right in the
center is the domain layer
it defines all the business logic of our
application no other layer is contained
is allowed to contain any bit of
business logic just this one layer
the domain layer is on the other hand
not not allowed to be aware of any
implementation details
everything to do with how the business
logic works needs to be defined in
abstract terms and implemented in the
outer layers
a common choice is to define your domain
logic using domain driven design
the application layer is the glue
between your business logic and the very
specific details of how your application
communicates with the outside world
it receives the raw input from the
framework
and does whatever is required to
translate it from into a form
understandable by the domain to perform
the operation that we wanted to perform
for example it may unmarshal the request
body
and maybe validate all the values before
passing it into the domain
it will then receive the results from
the domain layer
and translate them into whatever format
is expected by the outer layer
so this could be returning a specific
response format or maybe data in the
format that is expected by the database
the framework layer is the furthest from
the domain
and it's both the most abstract and the
most detailed
it treats the rest of the application as
a black box which just accepts some
input and then returns a response
it sees them as generic request and
response objects nothing else
it doesn't know anything about how the
application works
it's however full of specific
implementation details for all the
external interfaces that the application
deals with
the framework layer needs to understand
the http protocol
or how to establish a connection to a
particular flavor of a database
something the rest of the application
doesn't really care about
so the first thing that the hexagonal
architecture makes you do is
think about the different parts that
form your application
we start distinguishing between the
parts that form the core of your domain
versus all the external inputs and
outputs
the key difference between this approach
and the layered model
is that
we focus here on on the relationship
between the inside and the outside of
your application
as opposed to the left and right or top
to bottom view
which you end up when you think about
your application in terms of models
views and controllers
in the hex model all the inputs and
outputs are just treated as external
application adapters to your application
we typically have primary actors which
drive the application
so that could be your users other
systems on the internet or maybe your
automated test suite
and we also have secondary actors which
are the ones being driven by your
application
so that could be your database uh maybe
other things on the internet like other
cloud services or mailbox services
with or maybe other systems
other services within your system
traditionally to distinguish between
those primary and secondary actors we
put the primary ports and adapters on
the left hand side and the secondary
ones on the right
so how does this help achieve us help us
achieve maintainability
the key rule in this model is that
dependencies are only allowed to point
inwards what do i mean by that
when we think about the requests coming
from the outside the dependencies are a
little bit easier to visualize
the outer layers can call anything they
like from the inner layers and they can
reach out to the domain as much as they
like but they cannot reference anything
outside of themselves
for dependencies going out like
calling the database
we use dependency injection or inversion
of control
this is a quote from
craig walls explaining dependency
injection or di as it's commonly
abbreviated
he said traditionally each object a
response is responsible for obtaining
its own references to the objects it
collaborates with so its dependencies
when applying di
the objects are given their dependencies
at creation time by some external entity
that coordinates each object in the
system
so in other words dependencies are
injected into the objects
inversion of control uses interfaces to
achieve dependency injection
so the domain will define all the
functionality it requires from external
dependencies in abstract terms as
interfaces
it would then accept those interfaces in
its constructors
and call their functions throughout the
operation as if they were just some
black boxes that do the stuff that it
needs doing
the actual concrete implementations of
the of those interfaces will be passed
in at runtime
but the domain doesn't really care what
they are as long as the site they
satisfy the required interfaces
so that way we can keep the dependencies
pointing inwards only
the domain will not need to call out to
the application or framework layers
because it defines all the interfaces
within
itself and this in turn allows for
maintainability
because of this organization of
dependencies we can easily change one
part of the application without
affecting the rest of it
the point is to keep the changes local
if the domain needs to change we
shouldn't really need to touch any of
the outer layers
as long as the interfaces between them
stay the same
if the application or the framework
needs to change
then we shouldn't really need to touch
the business logic
as long as all the interfaces define
that the boundaries are still satisfied
so for example if we wanted to swap out
a mysql database for a nosql store or an
http interface for a command line
interface the core domain shouldn't
really need to change it shouldn't
really care about what database is being
used or how is the data being saved
it just needs to be able to pass the
data somewhere to be saved
and the hex model recognizes exactly
that and it really leverages the power
of abstractions or interfaces
it helps keep everything under control
and it prevents the business logic from
leaking all over the stack we define
interfaces at every boundary interfaces
are ports just like the ports on your
laptop which allow different inputs to
be plugged in any device which
understands your laptop sport can be
used with it
for example any headphones with a jack
cable would work when you plug them in
the jackpot or wouldn't they apple
that gives you the flexibility of to use
many pairs of headphones over time
without having to buy lots of dongles or
change your laptops every time
so each layer will define its ports or
interfaces
and then the outer layers will provide
adapters for those defined ports and
this is really why the architecture is
called ports and adapters it's also
worth pointing out that the hexagon is a
random choice
the idea was that each vertex will
represent a port so in reality the shape
will depend on how many ports your
layers expose
alistar coburn chose a hexagon because
he felt that it leaves enough space on
the whiteboard to then write the names
of all the ports into a diagram as
you're designing your system
he reckons we typically have about three
to five ports in our applications
there is no strict definition of what a
port really is
other than it's just an abstract apis
api exposed to the outer layers
so you could have a pentagon for example
or a square
or the actual representation of your
system
could probably look something like this
because there is no rule that every
layer needs to implement the exact same
number of ports
and then this architecture works equally
well for single monolith services or
microservices there is no real
difference here
hexagonal architecture corresponds well
to the test pyramid
we can put lots and lots of unit tests
in the domain layer because the discrete
units of domain and the business logic
should be really easy and really cheap
to test
unit tests are cheap to write and fast
to run
so it makes sense to focus them on the
domain so that our business logic is
well protected and tested often
then the further we go from the center
the more high level we want to get
so the application layer will mostly
used end-to-end tests or integration
tests because at this point we're
interested in testing the end-to-end
behavior
and the domain working together with the
application
and finally we can add some tests which
drive the application through the user
or the command line interface but
because they're slow to run and fairly
brittle and expensive to maintain we
don't have too many of those
and we certainly wouldn't expect them to
cover every possible scenario
most things in the framework layer like
the http router or the database adapter
they will probably come with their own
unit tests so there's no need to unit
test them ourselves
we can probably just rely on the ui
tests or the integration tests to verify
that they work as expected
we already have interfaces in place
because of dependency injection and
because those interfaces should define
dependencies which don't contain any
business logic
then any test doubles that you might
need to use
they should be fairly simple
whether you end up having to use mocks
or not it will depend on what your rules
and i kind of mean personal rules are
exactly
if we were to be very very rigorous
about the domain having no knowledge of
where the data comes from or where it
goes to
then it won't really be any
it won't really be calling any functions
to save to the database itself
it will be the application layer that
will be in charge of deciding where the
data goes and what happens to it
once it receives it or pass it it passes
it into the domain so the domain layer
is purely focused on data processing
so in that case in theory you shouldn't
have anything to mock out
in the domain unit tests
and then if you mostly write end-to-end
tests in your application in the
application layer
then there is no need to mock there
anything either because you actually
want to use the real database then
real life however sometimes has your
domain calling calling out some
dependencies through their interfaces
directly
so for example when you want to fetch an
existing object before updating it and
just cut that corner
so in this case you just have to mock
that call out
and i've never been a fan of the always
or never do things rules so i think in
some cases it's just fine to do
hexagonal architecture will naturally
encourage you to have lots and lots of
unit tests some end-to-end tests and a
few ui driven tests
at every layer an automated test
framework is just another adapter to
your ports
let's put it all together
hexagonal architecture introduces
structure and consistency into your
project
it's easy to navigate it's easy to
understand and it's easy to reason about
use case-centric architectures tend to
make sense to people
and maybe this is why we keep coming
back to this idea under different names
the hex architecture makes your
applications easy to change
because the inside and the outside
layers are loosely coupled
it supports evolutionary design because
there's no limits to how many ports you
can have
it makes your code easy to test
and the design of your code will reflect
exactly how the application works
if something is placed in the
application layer then you know that it
most likely will provide some sort of
service for handling requests and that
it won't define any business logic
the responsibilities of each component
are clear depending on where they are
and the structure of your code how your
files are actually organized on disk it
will follow that as that design exactly
in any application the code is
ultimately the most up-to-date
documentation of your business logic
sometimes the intended design is not
actually how the application works
so in the hex architecture we minimize
the risk of that happening by keeping
the core domain logic in one place
making it reusable and very testable
there is no single right answer to code
structure
end of the day it's whatever works for
you and for your use case sometimes the
hex architecture might not be the right
choice and that's fine
but if you don't know where to start
especially for a biggish commercial
project
i think it's a good one to try out
or maybe you can start out with a flat
structure and then move over to the hex
architecture over time
remember that the logic in your
application will expand and it will
change and morph over time
so almost don't expect to get it right
the first time
as bruce lee said be like water expect
to change and adapt over time
whatever you do aim for maintainability
and don't over complete don't over
complicate your structure keep it as
simple as possible but no simpler
go for the simplest solution for today
and don't worry about the future
prototype and experiment it will help
you raise questions you didn't even know
you should be asking
remember that good choices and best
practices come with experience
so play around with your code and share
share your ideas with the rest of the
community
seen the idea of ports and adapters
being reinvented so many times
but i'm sure there's plenty more to
discover